nous l'avions déjà signalé lors de notre
point d'étape au mois de février les
jeux ne peuvent plus se réduire un
simple tableau de médaille nous avons
changé d'époque et le CIO en a lui-même
pris conscience avec élaboration en 2018
d'une nouvelle norme visant à assurer
une meilleure prise en compte des
objectifs de développement durable et
l'exigence d'un héritage pour le pays
hôte
la ville de Paris l'État et le kosoop en
faisant le choix d'utiliser
prioritairement les infrastructures
disponibles et en développant des
programmes d'héritage délasses de
candidatures se sont résolument inscrits
dans ce nouveau modèle
les jeux doivent donc être utiles au
pays et laisser un héritage durable il
en va de leur acceptabilité
de même réussir l'organisation des Jeux
implique d’entraîner le pays dans un
projet positif de susciter
l'enthousiasme du plus grand nombre son
engouement populaire sans engouement
populaire comment peut-on espérer un
héritage positif et durable or nous
constatons que cet engouement peine à
s'installer même si la perspective des
Jeux peut sembler encore lointaine à
certains
qui plus est dans le contexte actuel
nombreux sont ceux qui ont exprimé du
dépit et une grande frustration face au
système de vente des billets assez
illisibles il faut le dire et leur prix
nous avons partagé cette frustration
bien que nous soyons conscients du
modèle économique des jeux
ceci ne peuvent donc pas se réduire à
des nuisances et des agréments pour les
Français en premier lieu les Franciliens
difficultés du réseau de transport
promesses de mise en ex en
accessibilité non tenue
accessibilité non tenue retard dans les
chantiers du Grand Paris
contrainte de déplacement du fait des
voies olympiques défi de la sécurisation
de l'événement et bien sûr l'enjeu du
coup des jeux pour la nation car
l'argent de la nation est bien engagé
dans le financement de l'olympiades d'où
la nécessité pour le Parlement d'exercer
à fond sa mission constitutionnelle de
contrôle et d'évaluation des politiques
publiques 13 confidenceurs publics
concourent au budget de la solideo à
hauteur de millions 7 des milliards 7
pardon d'euros s'agissant du conjoop
l'état la ville de Paris la région et la
métropole apportent une contribution de
100 millions d'euros mais le coût global
pour l'État sera plus élevé notamment en
raison des dépenses de sécurité que la
Cour des comptes a appelé à recenser de
façon précise dans un document de
ce qui n'est toujours pas fait à ce
stade outre ses dépenses l'État et les
collectivités territoriales devront
supporter diverses dépenses fiscales et
des dépenses de transport qui restent
encore à chiffrer
pardon un mot assez assez rapide sur la
question du tourisme qui est un enjeu
majeur dans un accueil des Jeux
olympiques mais nous avions nous en
avions parlé ici devant la commission en
février dans notre pré rapport avec
quelques points d'alerte qui depuis ont
été en partie corrigés puisque la
secrétaire la ministre délégué au
tourisme
coordonné les acteurs et que le retard
qu'on pouvait considérer en février a
été pour une part rattrapée mais pour
autant
pourtant on voudrait à ce sujet avoir
deux points d'alerte le premier c'est
sur la question de point de vigilance
disons le premier ça c'est la question
de l'hébergement d'urgence qui risque
d'être fragilisé notamment dans la
région
Île-de-France en effet plusieurs hôtels
ont passé des conventions avec l'État
pendant la crise sanitaire et pourrait
décider de revenir sur leur activité
économique première en vue des Jeux ce
qui peut se comprendre mais ça se
traduit par une une baisse importante de
l'hébergement d'urgence rien que pour
2022 sur la seule région Île-de-France
7500 place d'hébergement d'urgence ont
été
perdus et ce qui fragilise forcément
toute une toute un pan de politique
publique notamment celle qu'on appelle
le logement d'abord et la mise à l'abri
des personnes en grande précarité
ensuite dire que nous pensons que les
jeux sont le bon moment pour franchir
une nouvelle étape dans la régulation
des meublés touristiques vous le savez
Airbnb est un partenaire premium du
Comité international olympique et
pourrait héberger près de 500 000
touristes pendant les Jeux chacun de
nous constate que dans sa
circonscription les effets des meublés
de touristes sur les prix des logements
et les mers réclament des mesures fortes
pour mettre un terme à cette hémorragie
immobilière récemment souligné par une
mission interministérielle de
propositions de loi ont été déposées
nous devons maintenant nous en saisir
pour notre part nous proposons
l'enregistrement de l'ensemble des
meublés de tourisme territoire
l'abaissement du plafond des jours de
location autorisés pour les résidences
précises principales qui sont
aujourd'hui de 120 jours ce qui ne
correspond absolument pas à ce que
devrait être le statut d'une résidence
principale donc il faut en baisser le
nombre et puis bien sûr de débattre
notamment à l'occasion de la prochaine
loi de finances de l'assujettissement
des bleuets de tourisme à la TVA dans le
cadre du de dans un traitement disons
égalitaire avec
l'hôtellerie classique c'est une demande
des élus locaux c'est une demande des
maires c'est aussi une demande très
forte du secteur hôtelier dans notre
pays qui est quand même dans un pays
comme la France un secteur économique de
première ordre et qui subit une
concurrence qu'il considère
déloyale de la part des meublés de
touristes mettons à profit les mois qui
viennent pour réguler ce marché
nous nous l'avions également rappelé au
cours de notre point d’étape le dossier
de candidature de la ville de Paris
comportait des engagements ambitieux sur
les plans économiques
sociaux et environnementaux la signature
d'une charte sociale entre Paris 2024 et
les syndicats étaient un acte inédit et
nous espérons que les futurs grands
événements sportifs internationaux vont
pérenniser ce modèle après le succès de
la candidature française une charte
sociale définitive a été signée entre 5
organisations syndicales et trois
organisations patronales cette charte
comprenait 16 engagements relatifs à la
commande publique à la bonne prise en
compte des spécificités des PME et des
TPE à la prévention des discriminations
à la santé des salariés à la
sécurisation des parcours professionnels
par la suite la solideo c'est dotée
elle-même de sa propre charte dans
lesquelles elle s'est donnée trois
objectifs réserver 10% des heures
travaillées à l'insertion
professionnelle rendre accessible 25% du
montant des marchés au PME
TPE et structure de l'économie sociale
et solidaire et promouvoir un modèle
exemplaire dans le secteur de la
construction en luttant contre le
travail illégal contre les pratiques
anticoncurrentielles contre les
discriminations et à garantissant des
conditions de travail de qualité
nous avons regretté que les engagements
de la Charte sociale ne soient pas
chiffrées ce qui ne facilite pas le
suivi de leur mise en oeuvre la solideo
c'est dotée d'un dispositif de suivi
rigoureux actualisé chaque mois et
transmis à ses autorités de tutelle sa
mission n'est pas achevée mais nous
pouvons déjà constater un bilan très
positif
plus de 2 millions d'heures d'insertion
ont été réalisées soit 85 % de
l'objectif cible cet objectif devrait
donc être atteint et probablement même
dépasser sur les 3000 bénéficiaires près
de la moitié sont des résidents de la
Seine-Saint-Denis un peu plus d'un tiers
d'entre eux étaient des demandeurs
d'emploi de plus d'un an et la moitié
avait moins de 30 ans sans remettre en
cause ces excellents résultats nous
avons regretté la faible part des
contrats d'apprentissage dans les
contrats seulement 14%. nous avons
surtout alerté sur l'insuffisance du
dispositif du suivi de ces personnes
après la fin de leur contrat de travail
la seule idéo ne dispose pas de données
et bien que l'adrieste dit de France est
lancé des études de cohorte nous ne
connaissons pas pour leur le taux de
transformation de ces heures d'insertion
à l'emploi durable
le bilan apparaît positif également pour
les marchés passés avec les TPE et les
PME les montants engagés s'élèvent à 663
millions d'euros soit 36% du total
l'objectif de 25% de montant engagés et
donc largement dépassé et la promesse de
retombées économique locale tenue les
entreprises franciliennes toutes
catégories confondues ont bénéficié de
75% du montant des marchés
s'agissant des TPE et PME francilienne
se sont 65% des montants des marchés qui
leur ont été dévolus donc 15% pour
celles implantées en Seine-Saint-Denis
la seule vidéo a fait des conditions de
travail de la lutte contre le travail
illégal une priorité et nous saluons
l'engagement personnel de son directeur
général les chantiers olympiques n'ont
malheureusement pas échappé ou
travailler légal la solideo ayant
reconnu elle-même avoir été confrontée à
une centaine de travailleurs en
situation irrégulière sur un total de 10
000 personnes mobilisées sur les
chantiers cela paraît peu les
travailleurs sans papiers ont été depuis
régularisés et une procédure judiciaire
est en cours
a désormais engagé plus de 80% de ses
procédures d'achat qui se chiffre à 2
milliards 3 d'euros d'achat prévisionnel
nous avons constaté une captation
importante des retombées économiques
liés à l'organisation des Jeux par les
14 partenaires du CIO dit partenaires
top auquel reviennent 377 millions
d'euros les partenaires nationaux
c'est-à-dire les sponsors bénéficient
quant à eux de 750 millions d'euros ce
qui laisse un milliard deux d'euros pour
la commande publique classique
sur les prêts de 2000 fournisseurs du
conjoint 90% des fournisseurs du conjo
sont français parmi lesquels 75% de TPE
et de PME
beaucoup de marchés comporté des clauses
de responsabilité sociale et
environnementales et nous avons avec
Stéphane peu et nos administrateurs
c'est un déplacement assez instructif
qui permet de mettre un zoom sur
la situation de notre pays face à ce
projet et c'est un jeu de
l'industrialisation
sa rentrée dans les subtilités du droit
de la commande publique ce n'est pas
d'ailleurs l'objet aujourd'hui de notre
mission mais
on a on a pu voir que l'appel a
manifestation d'intérêt du cozloop
relatif à la fabrication des mascottes
qui avaient été publiées à mars 2021 ne
pouvait faire explicitement référence à
un taux de fabrication en France mais
entendez encourager les initiatives
créant de la valeur économique sociale à
l'environnemental sur les territoires
accueillants les Jeux Olympiques et dans
l'ensemble du pays il comportait
également une référence explicite à la
dynamisation des tissus économiques
locaux
pour de multiples raisons l'immense
majorité des peluches commercialisées en
France son produit en Asie et nous
avions donc beaucoup de raisons d'être
inquiets cette réalité industrielle
s'explique évidemment par l'écart du
coût de revient et par la différence de
prix des produits les mascottes n'y
échappent pas puisque une mascotte
produit en Chine est vend du 27 euros et
une mascotte produit en France 40 euros
pour le moment nous ne savons pas
combien de mascottes seront
effectivement fabriqués sur le
territoire national l'objectif initial
avait été fixé à 8%, mais pourraient
atteindre 30% à la fin des jeux
sans transition je passais de la
mascotte au transport
bon ça avait été un gros point d'alerte
en février et c'est quand même le sujet
sur lequel nous on considère au terme de
cette mission qu'on n'a pas beaucoup
avancé positivement et que toutes les
inquiétudes formulées au mois de février
non pas été n'ont pas été levé loin de
là
pour les réseaux de transport
franciliens les jeux apparaissent comme
une grande chance et une opportunité
unique à saisir pour accélérer leur
développement et leur modernisation le
défi logistique avec près de 600 000
personnes à transporter chaque jour sera
sans précédent c'est à peu près pour
avoir une idée c'est en plein mois
d'août le trafic
habituel des transports en Île-de-France
plus 15%. au mois d'août quand
habituellement au mois d'août c'est le
trafic habituel moins
40%. donc c'est un défi considérable
or notre inquiétude porte sur différents
aspects d'abord de nombreux chantiers du
Grand Paris Express accuse un retard
irrattrapable les lignes 16 et 17 du
Grand Paris surnommé les lignes
olympiques et devant des servir les
sites olympiques de la Seine-Saint-Denis
et le village des médias ne seront pas
prêtes pour les jeux le calendrier du
prolongement de la ligne 14 jusqu'à la
gare de Saint-Denis Pleyel donc le
village olympique apparaît désormais
très serré sans certitude s'agissant de
la partie sud de la ligne qui est elle
doit desservir Orly de plus les
Franciliens souffrent déjà aujourd'hui
de dysfonctionnement répété du réseau de
transport qui n'a toujours pas retrouvé
une activité normale depuis le la sortie
de la crise sanitaire dans ce contexte
et alors que les transports franciliens
sont très fragiles nous considérons que
l'ouverture à la concurrence des bus
parisiens prévus en 1er janvier 2025
donc
mise en place en 2024 concomitament au
jeu nous sommes une très mauvaise idée
nous avions préconisé un décalage de
cette date lors de notre point d'étape
une proposition de loi que j'avais
déposée a été discutée en masse en mars
dernier j'étais contraint de la retirer
suite à
sa dévitalisation Madame Valérie
Pécresse Présidente de la Région
Île-de-France ne souhaite pas pour
l'heure modifier le calendrier
initialement prévu alors que les
conséquences sociales d'une telle
décision pourront perturber le bon
déroulements des jeux j'ajoute que les
décrets pour que le président de la RATP
Jean-Castet conduisent des négociations
sociales sur cette ouverture à la
concurrence ne sont toujours pas connus
ni même publié ni même rédigé ce qui
rend tout à fait
un impossible de négocier dans de bonnes
conditions l'ouverture à la concurrence
en évoquant les transports nous évoluons
naturellement vers la question de leur
mise en Access par les spectateurs en
situation de handicap l'ensemble des bus
et tramways ainsi que l'ensemble des
gares ou ligne en cours de rénovation
permettront l'accueil des personnes à
mobilité réduite mais notre réseau ferré
et notamment le réseau souterrain le
métro est trop ancien pour être mis au
nord le gouvernement a donc prévu des
solutions mais les moyens manquent
passer de bus pas cette personnel pas
cette taxi en circulation et de
véhicules véritablement véritablement
adapté au handicap en ce sens la loi
olympique que nous avons voté récemment
en favorisant l'augmentation du nombre
de taxis accessibles aux personnes en
fauteuil roulant devraient améliorer la
situation plus largement sur le handicap
nous sommes interrogés sur le
développement de la pratique sportive
pour les personnes en situation de
handicap chacun conviendra les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques n'ont pas la
même exposition médiatique le décret
relatif aux événements d'importance
majeures inclut toujours pas les jeux
para ni même les grands événements
parasitifs à venir tels que le
championnat du monde de parade
athlétisme ou la Coupe du monde de rugby
en fauteuil ce décret doit également
inclure davantage à nos yeux
d'événements de sport féminin sa
révision est en cours et une nouvelle
liste sera soumise à la Commission
européenne d'ici la fin de l'année à nos
yeux il est donc essentiel que le
paraport soit mieux représenté un axe
crucial du développement de la pratique
des personnes en situation de handicap
consiste également à former des
encadrants dans les clubs à ce jour seul
1,5% des 180 000 associations sportives
se déclarent en mesure d'accueillir des
personnes en situation de handicap le
dispositif club inclusif n'aura permis
de former que 700 clubs d'ici la fin de
l'année 2023 nous devons à nos yeux
aller beaucoup plus loin et renforcer
les moyens alloués au sport et au
paraphe adapté
sujet sécurité donc les jeux c'est aussi
bien sûr le défi de la sécurisation de
l'événement un point sur lequel nous
n'avons pas le droit à l'erreur
la charge sera extrêmement lourde pour
nos forces de sécurité intérieure dans
un contexte de tension capacitaire
inquiétante que chacun aura pu constater
encore ces derniers jours
pour la seule cérémonie d'ouverture sur
la scène pas moins de 45000 policiers
seront mobilisés soit un cinquième des
effectifs nationaux de police et de
gendarmerie et l'armée sera chargée de
sécuriser la flotte composée de 180
embarcations sur la Seine
si l'État est responsable de la sûreté
dans les transports et sur la voie
publique la sécurisation décide de
compétition relève elle du kojob
le nombre d'agents de sécurité privée
nécessaire pour sécuriser les sites de
compétition mais estimé entre 20 000 et
30000 par jour effectivement qui ne sera
sans doute pas atteint les premiers
marchés publics attribués à mars dernier
par le cojoop à 28 entreprises
permettent à peine de couvrir la moitié
des ressources nécessaires
le coslop est en cours d'analyse de la
deuxième vague des marchés publics
relatifs à la sécurité publique qu'un
comporte 4
la troisième a été lancée au mois
d'avril mais les grands acteurs du
secteur et le groupement des entreprises
de sécurité privée ne soumission ne pas
pour le moment
dans ce contexte il semble difficile
d'envisager le recrutement d'un nombre
suffisant d'agents nous tenons toutefois
saluer le travail sans précédent qu'on
conduit le CNAPS l'émission locale et
Pôle emploi qui œuvrent depuis des mois
pour recenser non seulement les anciens
détenteurs d'une carte d'agent de
sécurité privée mais également les
presque 20 000 demandeurs d'emploi qui
ont été inscrits à un moment de leur
carrière dans les métiers de la sécurité
privée de même nous saluons la création
d'une nouvelle carte professionnelle
dite carte événementielle permettant de
former en 106 heures au lieu de 175
heures des étudiants ou des demandeurs
d'emploi qui souhaiteraient venir
renforcer les équipes de sécurité privée
notamment pour le contrôle des SAS et
les fouilles à l'entrée des sites de
compétition
malgré ses efforts con relèvent et qu'on
salue le recours aux forces de sécurité
intérieure sera sans doute nécessaire
pour pallier le déficit d'agent de
sécurité privée ce qui devra d'ailleurs
infiner être financé par le conjo
lui-même puisque c'est sa responsabilité
la sécurisation des sites de compétition
au-delà de ces sujets de préoccupation
transports sécurité les jeux présentent
bien évidemment aussi des visages un
visage positif
ces jeux ont d'ores déjà permis la
modification de la réglementation
relative à la lutte contre le dopage la
loi olympique que nous avons examiné au
mois de mai dernier enfin mis dans notre
code du sport en confort notre corps du
sport en conformité avec la convention
internationale contre le dopage dans le
sport que la France avait ratifiée en
2005 il était donc plus que temps
désormais des analyses génétiques
peuvent avoir lieu en matière de lutte
contre le dopage dans 4 cas expressément
prévu par la loi et encadré par elle et
notamment en cas de mutation génétique
dans un gène impliqué dans la
performance induisant une production
endogène d'une substance interdite
un mot sur les aspects aménagement
urbains et
héritage
des jeux en matière d'infrastructure bon
l'une des forces de la candidature de
Paris 2024 c'était d'avoir des jeux qui
allaient principalement ceux de rêver
sur des infrastructures existantes donc
très concrètement 95% des
infrastructures sportives utilisées pour
les jeux soit elles existent déjà soit
elles seront temporaires il y aura donc
pas contrairement à d'autres jeux
olympiques précédents il n'y aura pas
d'éléphant blanc à l'issue de ces jeux
c'est-à-dire des strastructures qui
deviennent ensuite vides obsolète ou qui
se dégradent ou qui n'ont pas d'usage et
qui représentent souvent des gâchis
insupportables pour les populations dans
l'organisation des Jeux Olympiques
les jeux en France et à Paris 2024 sont
à l'abri à l'abri de cette de ce risque
statuts des jeux la destination des
ouvrages qui composent le village des
médias ou le village olympique est
paralympique va permettre à un
département comme la Seine-Saint-Denis
qui m'est cher de bénéficier à la fois
de crèches de groupe scolaires d'école
nouvelle ou d'école rénovées et aussi
bien sûr de logement le contrat de
concession du centre aquatique olympique
à Saint-Denis chez moi comporte une
délégation de service public elle devra
permettre aux écoles du quartier de
bénéficier de créneaux horaire
spécifique afin de résorber l'écart
significatif entre les enfants du
département et les autres dans la
maîtrise de la natation et je rappelle à
ce sujet que aujourd'hui en
Seine-Saint-Denis la moitié des enfants
ne savent pas nager contre un quart des
enfants sur le reste du territoire
pour conclure nous souhaiterions aborder
le thème que nous avons le plus exploré
au cours de la seconde partie de nos
travaux le développement de l'activité
physique et sportive à l'école ce qui
sera une réponse à votre interrogation
madame la Présidente
toutes les personnes que nous avons
rencontrées sont unanime dans
littérature scientifiques les également
tout commence à l'école et d'un certain
point de vue tout finit à l'école
c'est là que se prennent les bonnes
comme les mauvaises habitudes que sans
que l'habitude sportif ou les
comportements sédentaires
par ailleurs l'école est plus que jamais
le lieu de l'égalité est plus d'un
enfant sur deux ne pratiquent pas de
sport en dehors de l'école
certains pourraient en conclure qu'il
faut davantage inciter les parents à
pousser leurs enfants vers la pratique
sportive vous en convenons parfaitement
et des dispositifs existent comme le
passeport qui poursuit sa montée en
puissance
tous les problèmes ne peuvent pas se
régler à l'école et nous ne faisons pas
partie de ceux qui attendent tout d'elle
cependant elle peut et doit faire
beaucoup la lutte contre l'inactivité
physique des jeunes est une priorité de
santé publique
tous nos interlocuteurs y compris
récemment c'était la semaine dernière à
l'occasion d'un déplacement des
directeurs d'école rencontrés à Trappes
nous ont alerté les enfants sont
essoufflés découragés par le moindre
effort physique leur capacité physique
en drastiquement diminué l'usage des
écrans cette intensifié depuis les
confinements nous le savons tous
face à cette réalité qui menace autant
le bien-être physique que mental de ces
futurs adultes que les finances sociales
de notre pays il est urgent d'agir
le cochon a développé un programme
d'éducation génération 2024 et le
ministère de l'Éducation nationale a mis
en place plusieurs dispositifs
d'augmentation de la pratique sportive
scolaire
est-ce que pour autant tout va mieux et
là ce nom
pour rester pudique nous avons constaté
que l'école se a encore un peu trop
lentement
les programmes des 30 minutes d'activité
physique quotidiennes ou les deux heures
de sport supplémentaires au collège sont
des dispositifs bienvenus mais
malheureusement il reste insuffisant
nous devons revaloriser l'enseignement
de l'EPS ou de nations sportives il n'y
aura pas
l'éducation physique et sportive offre
aux enfants un socle minimal d'activité
physique mais il présente aussi des
vertus pédagogiques essentielles goût de
l'effort respect de l'autre attention
porter à son corps esprit d'équipe et je
crois que nous pouvons tous nous
accorder au-delà de nos appartenances et
nos sensibilités politiques sur la
nécessité de cultiver ses valeurs chez
nos enfants
or les horaires de PS ne sont pas
effectifs en particulier dans l'école
primaire plusieurs
enquêtes l'ont démontré alors que
l'horaire officiel est de 3 heures
hebdomadaires beaucoup d'écoles
n'atteignent même pas les deux heures
faute le temps d'installation sportive
de proximité mais aussi il faut le dire
par manque de formation des professeurs
des écoles ou d'appétence de ces
derniers les heures consacrées à l'EPS
dans la formation initiale des
instituteurs sont ridiculement basses et
lorsque l'on regarde du côté de la
formation continue le moins que l'on
puisse dire que c'est une guerre mieux
les sessions de formation continue sont
en hausse depuis quelques années mais
nous sommes encore très très loin du
compte
nous demandons donc une revalorisation
de la discipline qui passe selon nous
par une augmentation des horaires de PS
4 heures au primaires et au collège
trois heures au lycée développement
massif des sections sportives scolaires
retour de l'EPS aux épreins de finale du
brevet internationaux de professeurs de
PS de seconde degré en appui au
professeur des écoles plutôt que des
intervenants extérieurs voilà quelques
mesures simples qui doivent selon nous
s’inscrire dans l'héritage des Jeux
Olympiques le sport à l'école c'est
aussi le sport scolaire qui concerne
trop peu d'enfants seulement 22% des
élèves du second degré sont licenciés à
l’uns et dans le primaire Lucette n'est
présente que dans 20% des écoles nous
avons qualifié lucepp de 5e route du
carreau olympique ces bénévoles car le
fonctionnement de l'icep relève presque
exclusivement du bénévolat on le
sentiment d'être les laisser pour compte
de l'héritage olympique auquel il
participe pourtant pleinement
son modèle est historiquement très
différent de celui de l'UNSS qui a été
qualifiée par la Cour des comptes de
paradeministration du ministère de
l'Éducation nationale l'UNSS dispose de
moyens de ressources humaines pour faire
fonctionner les associations sportives
notamment à travers le forfait de 3
heures des professeurs de PS les
professeurs des écoles bénévolent eux
bénéficierament de décharges ou
d'indemnités Périers éducatives le
résultat est sans appel le lucepp peine
à s'implanter dans les écoles participer
aux activités de l'ucep aujourd'hui
relèvent d'un acte militant or le
bénévolat est en crise et les
professeurs des écoles sont assaillis de
demande sociale nous devons donc leur
donner du temps et des moyens pour
qu'ils puissent engager leur classe dans
le sport scolaire nous proposons donc de
mieux associer Lucette au déploiement
des programmes d'héritage olympiques et
surtout de réserver une enveloppe
budgétaire dans chaque direction des
services départementaux de l'éducation
nationale au développement du sport
scolaire
enfin mieux valoriser le bénévolat pari
urgent et le ministère doit s'y atteler
indemnités Périers éducative décharge de
service activité pédagogiques
complémentaires les voies et les moyens
possibles ne manquent pas reste à
mobiliser la volonté politique
voilà on a été un peu long mais c'est la
conclusion la toute la toute dernière
conclusion dire j'avais prévu de
rajouter des choses sur l'école mais je
vais pas le faire simplement un message
c'est la question non la message c'est
celui du renforcement de l'éducation
physique et sportive comme une matière
éducative à part entière et pas
seulement le feu de se bouger mais aussi
d'apprendre l'altérité le goût de
l'effort le sens du collectif c'est tout
ça l'éducation physique revenir avec une
éducation physique et sportive qui
permettent d'avoir des notes au brevet
au bac d'avoir des facilités à
l'université tout ça nous semble
excessivement important et enfin pour
conclure dire qu'on a pris beaucoup de
plaisir à travailler sur les Jeux
Olympiques à travers les jeux il y a
plein de problématiques sociales qui qui
viennent et qui sont traités et que
d'ores et déjà Stéphane Mazar et
moi-même posons notre candidature à la
Commission pour que après les Jeux
Olympiques nous puissions
poursuivre cette mission par évaluer une
fois les lampions éteint ce qui sera
réellement ce qu'on donnait réellement
ces jeux pour le pays et qu'elle
héritage réelle nous pourrons
enregistrer
merci Monsieur Merci monsieur Lesquin
rapporteur en effet on a bien compris et
senti votre passion et votre appétence
pour ce sujet et votre volonté de
poursuivre mais je rappelle aussi à
l'Assemblée à ceux qui nous écoutent que
nous avons un groupe de travail qui qui
aussi est constitué qui travaille très
bien et qui verra aussi qu'elle est
l'héritage qui peut être fait de ces
jeux et d'ailleurs à la rentrée ils nous
feront un point d'étape pour nous
informer de d'où ils en sont mais les
travaux sont complémentaires
effectivement ce sujet est très très
vaste et il a besoin d'être exploré sous
toutes ses formes et pour cela nous
allons commencer par les par renaissance
pour les orateurs de groupe avec Belkhir
Belhaddad merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur les rapporteurs chers collègues
merci pour la qualité de ce rapport la
densité des sujets traités les
nombreuses recommandations que vous
faites et que je partage bien entendu
cet événement planétaire sera donc pas
douté une réussite et une fierté pour
notre pays c'est vrai qu'organiser des
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques et
d'une complexité inouïe mobilisant de
très nombreux acteurs néanmoins vous le
disiez à plusieurs reprises dans votre
rapport d'étape si les jeux s'annoncent
vertueux leur retombées économique et
social certificile à évaluer semble sur
certains points incertaine direz-vous la
même chose aujourd'hui et je veux pour
prendre l'exemple de l'hébergement dont
les besoins sont énormes autre sujet les
transports que vous avez évoqué cette
question s'inscrit dans un contexte de
retard des chantiers dans un cas
d'institutionnel d'éclatement des
compétences et celles de l'accessibilité
aux personnes handicapées c'est un des
grands regrets pour les lignes
existantes nous devons également trouver
une solution très rapidement avec la
région s'agissant de l'ouverture à la
concurrence des bus parisiens le
calendrier d'ouverture à la concurrence
telle qu'il est prévu aujourd'hui n'est
pas tenable
vous avez raison d'évoquer la question
de l'héritage un point central pour
faire de notre pays une nation sportive
à ce sujet je voudrais vous interpeller
sur deux d'entre eux le modèle de Jésus
développé dans le cadre de ces Jeux
Olympiques à travers tous les sujets que
vous avez pu aborder donc Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques Paris 2024
vous paraît-il de nature à être dupliqué
pour l'organisation d'autres grandes
manifestations voir à l'exporter comme
l’ont fait les organisateurs de Londres
2012 est un enjeu également de
souveraineté la deuxième question que je
voudrais évoquer avec vous concerne la
question du financement des équipements
sportifs structurant qui est majeur dans
notre pays quels sont à votre avis les
accompagnements nécessaires pour être au
rendez-vous je vous remercie merci
monsieur le député pour le rassemblement
national angélique Franck
si madame la Présidente messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues je tenais
dans un premier temps à souligner la
qualité de vos travaux et vous en
remercier le rassemblement national est
ferme l'accessibilité des jeux par
l'opinion publique passe tout d'abord
par la sécurité ne nous concitoyens
durant cet événement de grande envergure
notamment depuis la violence les
violences lors de la finale de la Ligue
des Champions mais elle passe également
par l'héritage matériel concernant
l'aménagement urbain les différentes
infrastructures sportives et le
transport
or ce plan héritage et durabilité est
irrémédiablement une promesse
d'amélioration de la qualité de vie dans
les collectivités hautes et alors qu'on
s'attend à des infrastructures
intelligentes et polyvalentes qui
pourront participer à répondre aux
besoins des Français ainsi qu'à une
amélioration des réseaux de transport
nous peinons à trouver un seul exemple
en la matière
pour ne parler que du transport les deux
tiers du Grand Paris ne seront pas
réalisés et pour le moment les lignes de
métro les plus empruntées ne seront que
plus surchargées et délabrés à l'été
2024 les émeutiers ont d'ailleurs
commencé le travail la semaine dernière
d'autant plus qu'on nous vend depuis le
début des travaux pour les personnes en
mobilité réduite mais formellement si
les Parisiens ne peuvent pas prendre le
métro à la moindre intempéries
aujourd'hui je doute que les personnes
en mobilité réduite le puits avec 13,5
millions de visiteurs en plus
j'ai d'ailleurs pu observer hier que le
rapport fait les mêmes observations et
qu'il n'est pas non plus optimiste sur
le sujet le gouvernement doit se montrer
transparent entre les étudiants les
étudiants du CROUS expulsés pour loger
les autres et les perquisitions du kojob
et de la solideo le dossier inquiète et
a juste titre ce n'est pas faux d'être
alerté surtout ces risques en amont
ainsi alors que nos concitoyens
commencent d'ores et déjà à faire des
sacrifices pour l'organisation de ces
jeux que pouvons-nous leur assurer
véritablement sur ces héritage quel
serait les solutions je vous remercie
merci madame la députée pour elle est
finie dupez Jérôme Legavre merci madame
la Présidente messieurs le rapport que
vous venez de nous présenter fourmis
d'éléments et d'informations on a bien
compris notamment qu'en termes de
transport le chaos et d'ores et déjà
annoncé KO dans les responsables sont
directement le gouvernement et la
présidente de région je tiens quand même
à le rappeler
plusieurs interrogations demeurent en
matière de droit des travailleurs de
travailleurs sans papiers d'atteinte aux
libertés alors je me concentrerai sur un
certain nombre de questions
les logements d'abord il manque 120 000
logements en Seine-Saint-Denis plusieurs
logements sont annoncés je n'ai pas eu
de réponse à mes interrogations
concernant la nature de ces logements et
en particulier la proportion de
logements sociaux dans dans ce cadre
qu'en est-il des étudiants logés
aujourd'hui en cité universitaire du
CROUS et donc qu'au joue demande
l'éviction durant la période des JO ce
qui est quand même particulièrement
choquant enfin vous avez évoqué la
charte en faveur de l'emploi et vous la
crédité de transparence exemplaire au 13
juin 2023 129 accidents de travail sur
les chantiers ont été recensés
l'adriette ça qualifié la problématique
des travailleurs sans papiers de
récurrentes exemplarité on peut se poser
la question pourquoi une charte alors
que le code du travail aurait simplement
à s'appliquer étant donné les volumes
d'heures d'insertion cité le le manque
de contrats cumulés devrions-nous en
déduire que l'exemplarité des JO
consiste à octroyer des contrats de 4
mois à des habitants dont le rapport
souligne lui-même qu'on a aucune idée de
ce qu'ils deviennent ensuite avez-vous
pu savoir pourquoi seuls sont décédés et
pourquoi l'insertion professionnelle
est-elle systématiquement à collée à
résidant des quartiers prioritaires de
la ville n'est-il plus possible dans ce
pays selon le code du travail
d'embaucher en CDI avec un mois d'essai
voilà quelques questions que je
souhaitais vous poser merci monsieur le
député pour les républicains Maxime
minot merci madame la Présidente
messieurs les rapporteurs au-delà de la
question de l'organisation des Jeux qui
nous préoccupent tous Actuellement la
question de l'héritage est un des enjeux
majeurs des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de Paris 2024 héritage
matériel mais aussi immatériel mais
notamment en avant lors de la
candidature portée devant le CIO alors
votre mission d'information a brosser un
champ large d'ailleurs au-delà de vos
prérogatives d'ailleurs qui vient
compléter d'ailleurs les travaux du
groupe de travail chargé du suivi de la
préparation des jops de Paris 2024 j'ai
deux questions qui me sont venues en
vous écoutant notamment sur les enjeux
de sécurité puisque le groupe de travail
que je coupe réside avec benkir a fait
un large focus sur le sujet donc je
voulais bien évidemment partager votre
point de vigilance sur le sujet mais
pouvez-vous nous en dire plus sur les
personnes auditionnées sur le sujet un
deuxième point qui m'est venu également
lors de de votre présentation c'est sur
le un point d'héritage important c'est
le nettoyage de la scène est-ce que vous
pouvez nous détailler ce point puisque
c'est un héritage vraiment qui qui sera
visible de tous et enfin pour en revenir
à vos prérogatives votre rapport
souligne la prise de conscience
collective d'une certaine inactivité de
notre jeunesse due en partie aux
conséquences de la crise sanitaire vous
soulignez également l'impact qu'auront
ces jeux notamment au niveau scolaire
sur l'encouragement à la pratique du
sport toutefois n'a-t-il pas un risque
d'effet pervers avec une baisse subite
de l'activité sportive poste Jo malgré
les moyens qui sont déployés donc ma
question est simple comment faire pour
que cette pratique perdure dans le temps
et avez-vous identifié des axes à mettre
en place pour que perdure cet héritage
sportif je vous remercie merci Monsieur
député pour les démocrates Laurent
esconégoce
merci madame le Président c'est monsieur
le rapporteur cher Stéphane Ness votre
travail est aussi vaste que le chantier
des Jeux Olympiques est aussi ambitieux
que la construction de la ligne TGV
Paris Toulouse dont vous alerter
d'ailleurs sur les incessants retard on
l'attend elle va finir par arriver du
fait de son ampleur votre rapport
appelle donc à de très nombreuses
questions si je tenterai ici de me
concentrer sur les particuliers points
d'attention soulevés par le groupe
démocrate le premier enjeu porte sur le
développement du tourisme hors capital
comme le relève très justement votre
rapport les effets sur Paris des Jeux
Olympiques en terre d'augmentation du
tourisme seront limitées dès lors
comment assurer que le public
international soit orienté au cours de
ces jeux sur la découverte des autres
villes concernées par cette
manifestation les JO doit être
l'occasion de développer le tourisme
national et non plus seulement parisien
c'est ce que devrait notamment permettre
les French tours que compte mettre en
œuvre la mini sur du tourisme Olivia
Grégoire en lien avec les comités
régionaux du tourisme pour faire
découvrir nos beaux territoires
avez-vous eu l'occasion au cours de
votre mission de rencontrer ces comités
afin de de la préparation de ces
circuits touristiques
tout autre sujet celui de handisport des
associations sont très nombreuses à
réclamer une plus grande inclusivité des
Jeux paralympiques en effet les
compétitions sont très majoritairement
tournées vers les personnes en situation
de handicap moteur
occultant ainsi les personnes ayant des
déficiences intellectuelles comment
pallier à cette discrimination j'en
profite d'ailleurs pour rappeler à
mettre davantage en lumière les
paraportives trop peu exposés
médiatiquement les femmes en situation
de handicap ne sont que 10% à pratiquer
un sport je salue à ce titre le travail
de l'association ASEI de mon territoire
qui vise à encourager la pratique
sportive chez ce public enfin qu'elle
doit être selon vous la position que
devra tenir la France pays de la loi
1905 et de la lutte contre les
communautarismes sur le port de signes
religieux ostentatoire en tout genre
pendant les épreuves de la compétition
je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député pour les
socialistes et apparentés
merci madame la Présidente tout d'abord
au nom du groupe socialiste et apparenté
je souhaite vivement et chaleureusement
remercier les deux corps rapporteurs
pour la qualité de leurs travaux
travaux menés avec vraiment beaucoup de
sérieux et je crois beaucoup de finesse
dans pour nos territoires terre
d'accueil qui sont les terres d'accueil
des Jeux olympiques et paralympiques il
est essentiel de se projeter dans
l'après jop 2024 la préparation de ces
jeux demande des sacrifices pour les
habitants et les habitants des
territoires concernés notamment les
habitants et les habitants de
Seine-Saint-Denis avec des nuisances
liées notamment aux travaux
préparatoires et il est tout à fait
normal que ce grand événement sportif
puisse ensuite déboucher sur des
dynamiques positives et à long terme sur
nos territoires j'aimerais pour ma part
revenir sur l'impact des Jeux Olympiques
sur le développement des fédérations
sportives scolaires dans nos
établissements
selon l'Observatoire national de
l'activité physique et de la sédentarité
73%, 73% des jeunes de 11 à 17 ans
n'atteignent pas les recommandations de
60 minutes d'activité physique par jour
jouent un rôle majeur dans la lutte
contre l'inactivité sportive de nos
jeunes pour que le sport soit accessible
à toutes et à tous il doit être
financièrement abordable avec une
moyenne d'une licence à 20 euros
l'effédérations sportives scolaires
permettent aux jeunes des milieux
défavorisés d'avoir accès à un plutôt
grand nombre de sport au cours de vos
auditions messieurs les rapporteurs
avez-vous pu avoir un panorama de la
situation actuelle des fédérations
sportives nous on a bien vu que entre
2018 et 2021 il y avait une perte par
exemple pour les collèges de cent mille
licenciés ce qui est pour moi énorme et
que aujourd'hui semble-t-il il y a une
reprise mais qu'elle n'est pas à la
hauteur du préco vide
donc j'aimerais on aimerait savoir ce
que vous pensez du rayonnement des Jeux
Olympiques 2024 est-ce que cela permet
est-ce qu'il permettront de redynamiser
et de dynamiser à long terme les
fédérations sportives quelle mesure
doivent être mises en place selon vous
pour que chaque élève à l'école vit à
l'école puisse découvrir la pratique du
sport qu'il souhaite merci merci madame
la députée pour horizon et apparentés
Béatrice Bellamy
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues chers rapporteur je vous
remercie pour la présentation de ce
rapport fui de fruits de longs mois de
travail et résultat de votre
collaboration il nous permet de mieux
appréhender cet événement majeur et de
nous en rapprocher toujours un peu plus
car comme vous le citez
387 jours nous séparent de ces épreuves
elles feront de la France durant
plusieurs semaines le pays sur lequel
les yeux du monde seront rivés ces jeux
sont une opportunité pour notre pays une
opportunité de montrer aux athlètes aux
délégations tout ce que nous aurons pu
collectivement mettre en oeuvre pour
leur permettre de performer dans les
meilleures conditions une opportunité
économique évidemment une opportunité
vertueuse également avec une mise en
oeuvre responsable et durable une
opportunité pour nos territoires avec de
nombreuses retombées et fait positifs
pour ma part je souhaite revenir sur les
chantiers en cours les TPE qui oeuvrent
sont investis d'une véritable mission de
valorisation de notre savoir-faire
français la solideo s'était donné pour
objectif d'engager 534 millions d'euros
de marché auprès des TPE PME et
structure de l'économie sociale et
solidaire
en juin
2023 vous nous avez fait remarquer que
ces objectifs avaient été atteints et
même dépassés avec 363 millions d'euros
engagés au profit de 1891 tpeme et 99
structures de l'essence réparties dans
99 départements c'est un point très
positif qu'il faut indéniablement
relever et qui je crois mérite d'être
publiquement salué maillon fort de la
chaîne de réussite ces entreprises n'ont
de cesse d'innover et je pense
particulièrement une entreprise
vendéenne Hoffman green pionnière dans
le béton bas carbone comme celui utilisé
sur les chantiers des Jeux Olympiques
cependant dans votre rapport vous
recommandez de prêter une attention
particulière à la limitation des marchés
de sous-traitants dans la dernière phase
du second œuvre pourriez-vous messieurs
les rapporteurs nous préciser votre
recommandation numéro 10 et nous
détailler les constats que vous auriez
pu faire ainsi que les points
d'amélioration attendus nous souhaitons
ons tous que ces jeux continuent plus
que jamais de mettre en valeur nos
entreprises et territoires je vous
remercie madame la député pour
écologiste nubes Francesca Pasquini
merci madame la Présidente messieurs les
rapporteur mes chers collègues tout
d'abord je souhaite saluer au nom du
groupe écologiste le travail de grande
qualité menée par Stéphane Mazar et
Stéphane peu sur un sujet essentiel à la
vitalité économique et culturelle de
notre pays les citoyens ont droit à la
transparence la plus totale sur cet
événement inédit si nous nous
réjouissons de nombreuses retombées
attendues tant au plan économique
culturel et de la priorité accordée au
sport en 2024 certains points nous
paraissent encore vague et méritent
d'être éclairci tout d'abord vous
abordez dans un paragraphe important la
question des SAS mis en place par le
ministre de la Ville afin de désengorger
l’hébergement d'urgence en Île-de-France
si le ministère se défend en public de
d'établir aucun lien avec les Jeux
Olympiques on peut en douter au regard
des chiffres que vous avancez l'approche
des grands événements sportifs
internationaux risquent de provoquer une
baisse de 3000 à 4000 places hôtelières
d'hébergement d'urgence ma première
question est donc la suivante comment
mieux Co cette stratégie de
désengorgement je souhaiterais aborder
un dernier sujet particulièrement au
regard des événements de ces derniers
jours celui de la sécurité vous le
rappelez la Cour des comptes estime
entre 22000 et 33000 le besoin quotidien
d'agent de sécurité privée sur les sites
les sites de compétition auquel
s'ajoutent 35000 agents de force de
sécurité intérieure et 10000 militaires
les événements lors du match avec
Liverpool ont laissé un souvenir amer au
supporter et susciter la condamnation
unanime des instances sportives
anglaises plusieurs rapports y compris
du gouvernement ont également pointé les
dysfonctionnements policiers et
organisation organisationnelles
j'aborderai donc immédiatement cette
question épineuse mais nécessaire ne
faut-il pas revoir le chemin de maintien
de l'ordre et notamment la question de
l'usage des gaz lacrymogènes et aussi je
tiens à souligner un poids à un point
important qui était dans votre rapport
celui des moyens du tribunal de Bobigny
que j'ai visité donc si les moyens de
police augmentent de 300%, il faut aussi
par conséquent que les moyens de ce
tribunal puissent augmenter cette toute
la chaîne pénale qui doit être renforcée
merci madame la députée pour jédère UPS
Soumia bouroa
merci madame la Présidente
monsieur les rapporteurs chers collègues
je voudrais tout d'abord vous remercier
pour la qualité de ce rapport elle
travaille que vous avez réalisé dans un
temps record vous nous avez fait un
premier point sur la sécurité les
transports il y a quelques mois et je
souhaite revenir sur le sujet au combien
compliqués en Île-de-France les
transports en commun je suis une élue de
Seine-Saint-Denis tout comme toi
Stéphane et je ne peux qu'alerter à mon
tour sur la situation très dégradée de
ceci en particulier dans le contexte
d'ouverture à la concurrence j'appelle à
la responsabilité sur ce sujet pour ne
pas rendre impossible la vie des
habitants et les habitants de et de
revenir sur cette mauvaise décision cela
étant dit je souhaite aborder la
pratique sportive à l'école dans le dans
le temps qui m'est imparti même si
j'aurais tendance à faire sur
différents points que vous avez évoqués
la pratique sportive est aussi traversée
par les inégalités de classe de genre
vouliez aller handicap je pense que le
rôle de l'école doit être compensé doit
compenser ces inégalités ce qui n'est
pas le cas actuellement le PS est une
matière à part entière et indispensable
dans ce cadre en primaire
est indispensable à la santé publique au
bien-être au bout de l'effort aux
collectif et ça doit être une priorité
dès le plus jeune âge et dans de très
bonnes conditions donc articuler les
nouveaux dispositifs comme les 30
minutes par jour les deux heures en
collège avec une revalorisation de l'EPS
et donc indispensable je vous remercie
merci madame la députée pour le groupe
liote Stéphane Lenormand
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur les
rapporteurs à mon tour je tiens à saluer
la qualité de votre travail sur un sujet
important mais je dirais qu'avec de
Stéphane à la barre il ne pouvait pas en
être autrement et c'est un autre
Stéphane qui vous le dit en termes de
solidarité bien entendu plus
[Musique]
sérieusement je voudrais pour ne pas
reprendre un certain nombre de propos
qui ont été tenus par mes collègues
avoir votre avis sur les outre-mer et
les territoires ruraux en termes de
retombées économique à tous les niveaux
je pense qu'il ne faut pas oublier qu'il
est important que cet événement majeur
pour notre pays
histoire que le calme revienne parce
qu'en fait moi je ne vous entends
absolument pas et je suppose que les
rapporteurs n'entendent pas plus que moi
donc je vous propose de recommencer
toute cette séquence afin que nous
puissions bien vous entendre
merci
non non mais parce qu'en fait moi j'ai
absolument pas entendu le début de
l'intervention je ne sais absolument pas
ce qui s'est passé
ceci en soi quand même dans une
situation qui va peut-être remettre en
cause ce beau rendez-vous parce que si
au niveau des épreuves sportives je ne
suis pas très inquiet sur ces deux
dimensions j'aimerais avoir un peu si
vous avez eu quelques retours quelques
explications ça peut être technique ça
peut être lié au marché public est-ce
que les appels d'offres ont été bon
est-ce qu'il y a beaucoup de contentieux
sur les marchés je sais pas si vous avez
quelques informations sur ce sujet et
enfin sur sur l'élément que vous avez
évoqué sur la dimension du sport c'est
un constat que je partage en tant
qu'enseignant je pense qu'il y a
vraiment là à mon sens une réflexion qui
doit être beaucoup plus large et plus
approfondie et qui doit naturellement
repenser complètement les objectifs que
l'on peut y mettre dans l'éducation
nationale au niveau du sport et ça
commence de l'école au collège est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est pas plus sur
ce genre de réflexion qu'il faut aller
pour profiter de l'effet boost des Jeux
Olympiques et que cela s'installe dans
une continuité pour que nos enfants
réapprennent le goût du sport merci
merci mon cher collègue donc maintenant
c'est Stéphane ou Stéphane qui répond
donc c'est Stéphane très bien
merci pour pour l'ensemble de vos
interventions et on va essayer de
répondre donc Stéphane peu et moi-même
donc à vos questions
on va essayer de les prendre un peu par
thème sans forcément nommer celui qui
nous a posé la question de manière
précise
la sécurité
alors c'est vrai que la sécurité on
l'avait déjà traité de manière assez
importante au mois de au mois de février
lors de la présentation du point d'État
parce qu'on se disait il est important
d'alerter sur les enjeux de sécurité et
sur la nécessité qu'il y a à monter en
puissance sur la capacité à recruter et
à faire venir des demandeurs d'emploi
des étudiants sur ces métiers là qui
vont nécessiter beaucoup de ressources
humaines puisque encore une fois les
chiffres sont à l'être entre 25000 et 30
000 agents de sécurité privée au
quotidien
on l'a salué dans notre rapport
franchement c'est vrai que les pouvoirs
publics quand même se sont emparés du
sujet et ils ont mis en place un certain
nombre de dispositifs qu'on a qu'on a
indiqué que j'ai indiqué tout à l'heure
pour pour attirer des candidatures
mais le constat il est celui-ci on sait
que on n'aura pas le nombre qui dans une
sécurité privée donc il faudrait
effectivement il faut d'ores déjà
c'était le rapport de la Cour des
comptes d'ailleurs qui le disait on l'a
dit également et on continue à le dire
il faut il faut bien évidemment se
projeter sur sur les moyens à mettre à
la disposition du corps pour sécuriser
les lieux les lieux de compétition donc
ça passera par la sécurité les forces de
sécurité intérieure l'armée dans
certains cas
après il faut aller jusqu'au processus
des appels d'offres donc aujourd'hui on
est au milieu du gué
il faut aller jusqu'au bout alors votre
question c'est de savoir qu'est-ce qui
explique aujourd'hui le peu d'engouement
pour des entreprises de répondre aux
appels d'offres et puis pour les
particuliers d'embrasser cette
profession quand on les demandeurs
d'emploi étudiant et qu'on peut y
trouver un certain intérêt
bon il y a déjà une désinfection pour
ces métiers depuis de longues années
c'est quand même des métiers qui sont
très engageants avec des horaires très
atypiques et bien évidemment que le
covid n'a fait accélérer
ce manque d'appétence pour pour ces
métiers avec des horaires atypiques
comme je le disais et qui demande donc
voilà une conciliation entre sa vie
personnelle et sa vie professionnelle
importante et puis il y avait aussi un
problème de la rémunération de ces
agents de sécurité il savait partie
d'ailleurs des éléments qui ont été
travaillés en vue justement de
l'objectif des Jeux Olympiques puisque
je crois que c'est au 1er janvier oui
c'est au 1er janvier 2023 qu'une que la
convention collective donc a été
rediscutée et que des que des
augmentations de salaire
ont vu le jour donc voilà donc on a un
contexte c'est le contexte général sur
ces métiers dit en tension qui fait que
aujourd'hui on a on a on a on n'est pas
au rendez-vous donc des de ces
ressources humaines après il y a des
entreprises qui aujourd'hui n'ont
toujours pas répondu aux appels d'offres
et alors une partie de l'explication ce
sont si ces entreprises qui ont des
marchés pérennes récurrents
et qui ne veulent pas aujourd'hui
délaisser leur clientèle habituel pour
aller sur un événement one shot au
moment des Jeux Olympiques donc il y a
aussi cette difficulté là et là pour le
coup qu'on peut comprendre de la part de
la part des entreprises
donc voilà donc c'est c'est un sujet
c'est un sujet bien identifié c'est un
sujet sur lequel le gouvernement
travaille voilà mais on est bien
évidemment encore une fois un peu
inquiet sur sur le résultat mais il
faudra relever le déficit de le défi de
sécurité et l'État devra devra trouver
les moyens de sécuriser tous les lieux
de compétition au delà bien évidemment
de ce qui lui incombe de prime abord
c'est à dire les lieux de transport et
l'espace public
monsieur minot justement sur le sujet
sécurité vous vous
nous demandiez
quelles avaient été nos interlocuteurs
donc nous on a auditionné le CNAPS le
délégué
ministériel
à la stratégie il y a la sécurité
la Fédération Française de la sécurité
privée
le GES monsieur Khoury
en lien un peu avec les sujets de
sécurité on s'est aussi on a aussi
auditionné les responsables du tribunal
de Bobigny
et puis Michel cadeau donc à trois
reprises a été auditionnée par nos soins
et à chaque fois bien évidemment on est
revenu sur le sur le sujet de la
sécurité
monsieur minot sur la
baignabilité de la scène donc ça c'est
un des enjeux en termes d'héritage
important
l'objectif c'est de rendre donc la scène
praticable pour les nageurs et pour ceux
qui aiment
dès 2025
des moyens importants sont mobilisés
c'est je crois 1,4 milliards d'euros
pour arriver à cet objectif et les
dernières analyses qui ont été réalisées
au mois de juillet et août 2022
sont plutôt encourageants puisque 91%
des mesures quotidiennes de la qualité
de l'eau était était bonne donc voilà
donc on est on est sur une bonne
trajectoire et l'objectif en termes
d'héritage d'avoir une scène mise à la
disposition du public pour pour les
baignades
étant passe étant pas être relevé
tu veux dire quelques mots et puis après
j'essaierai de reprendre sur un certain
nombre de sujets
voilà bon on va continuer notre
alternance
moi je voudrais réagir d'abord remercier
parce que il semble se dégager quand
même au moins une certaine unanimité ici
dans cette commission sur la question de
la place que doit reprendre
l'éducation physique et sportive comme
une matière pédagogique à part entière
donc je passe plusieurs intervenants
Soumia Fatiha mais aussi beaucoup
d'autres ont évoqué ce sujet et donc
voilà je pense que ça peut être une une
proposition extrêmement forte que on
aborde la question du sport scolaire
d'une manière totalement
différente que ce qu'on le fait
aujourd'hui en renforçant toutes les
structures d'appui et que sont lucept
UNSS
dire un mot
également sur ce qu'a dit belkir sur
comme comment on met à profit et on
conserve l'héritage d'un certain nombre
de structures qui nous ont permis de
réaliser les jeux si j'ai bien compris
il va y avoir une loi prochainement qui
va venir en discussion notamment pour
étendre l'émission de la Société du
Grand Paris sur la phrase toutes les
infrastructures de transport notamment
pour mettre en oeuvre le plan sur les
les RER
régionaux donc ça c'est une piste
intéressante et moi je pense je donne un
avis que c'est pas dans le rapport mais
je réponds à la question de Melker je
pense qu'une structure comme la solideo
c'est quand même
on décrit souvent la puissance publique
et l'intervention publique mais enfin la
seule idéo qui a été au rendez-vous
du point de vue calendaire de tous les
chantiers c'est un équipement c'est une
structure publique avec un animé par des
des aménageurs publics et des gens qui
ont fait toute leur carrière à commencer
par le directeur général monsieur
Ferrand dans dans
l'aménagement public on voit bien la
force et la rigueur qui a été celle de
la seule idéo pour à la fois respecter
les délais respecter le cahier des
charges ensuite deux mots quand même
enfin plus que deux mots mais rapidement
sur ce que disait mon collègue Jérôme le
gap sur
les infrastructures les logements
leur équilibre leur capacité à répondre
aux besoins des habitants de du
département
je pense qu'on a pas de mal à converger
sur ce que nous préconisons sur le sujet
mais je voudrais dire non pas pour
exonérer le comité d'organisation des
Jeux Olympiques et de la solideo mais
quand même un peu c'est que toute la
programmation du village des médias
comme du village olympique c'est fait
sur la base des plans locaux d'urbanisme
et des préconisations des plans locaux
de l'habitat donc par exemple si je
prends le village olympique qui est à
cheval sur trois villes Saint-Denis
Saint-Ouen et l'Île-Saint-Denis et ben
les programmes locaux de l'habitat et
les programmes locaux de l'urbanisme
n'étant pas tout à fait les mêmes parce
que il y a pas forcément tout à fait les
mêmes ambitions politiques d'une ville à
l'autre et ben les réalisations et les
et les transformations du village
olympique en logements se fera pas en
proportion de logements sociaux en
protection de logements dédiés en
contrôle des prix à la à la vente des
logements tout à fait de la même manière
au sein même du village olympique selon
qu'il se situe sur l'une des trois
communes puisque c'est les documents
d'urbanisme et des préconisations en
matière d'habitat de chacune des villes
qui qui a présidé à la réalisation du
village olympique mais c'est valable
pour le village des médias donc j'ai
envie de dire quand la programmation ne
va pas quand la programmation poste
olympique ne convient pas c'est à chacun
des maires qu'il faut demander des
comptes
pour faire pour faire simple
ensuite dire
alors
dès le pré rapport en février on avait
attiré l'attention sur un certain nombre
de d'accidents du travail et notamment
sur la question des sans-papiers
bon d'abord
les Jeux Olympiques on est passé vite là
dans le rapport mais on l'avait dit plus
dit en février pour la première fois
dans l'organisation des Jeux Olympiques
les partenaires sociaux sont autour de
la table et du comité d'organisation et
de la solideo monsieur le Medef hier
représenté et les syndicats de salariés
sont représentés par l'intermédiaire de
Bernard Thibault il y a une charte
sociale qui a été rédigée il y a trois
près de 300.000 euros qui ont été
consacrés par la solidaire pour qu'il y
ait une permanence syndicale quotidienne
sur le chantier même des Jeux Olympiques
c'est ce qui a permis d'ailleurs que
plus de 100 salariés
sans papier a été régularisé ce qui
n'est pas toujours ce qui n'est pas
toujours le cas et que
si on écoute les syndicats du bâtiment
le fait qu'il y ait eu
trois fois plus d'inspection du travail
avec un corps d'inspecteur du travail
dédié au chantier des Jeux Olympiques
nous le considérons et avec Bernard
Thibault avec lequel nous avons beaucoup
discuté nous le considérons comme un
acquis justement de la place des
syndicats dans l'organisation même des
chantiers et de l'organisation des Jeux
ce qui fait que
le nombre d'accidents du travail sur les
chantiers des Jeux Olympiques
quand il y en a un c'est déjà un deux
trois mais selon les syndicats du
bâtiment et notamment le syndicat
majoritaire qui est la CGT du bâtiment
ils sont beaucoup plus faibles que la
moyenne des chantiers du bâtiment
notamment grâce à la présence permanente
des syndicats sur le site et à la au
nombre de visites de l'inspection du
travail multipliée par 3 la remarque que
l'on fait et il y a une question qui a
été posée là-dessus là où on aurait pu
nous semble-t-il être
encore
plus efficace
c'est que certes on est soumis enfin la
seule idéo et le Kojo je dirais la seule
idée où elle Peugeot sont soumis
au code des marchés publics mais ils
l'ont admis eux-mêmes le code des
marchés publics
n'interdit pas
dans les clauses de limiter le niveau de
sous-traitance et ça n'a pas été fait et
forcément on sait que plus il y a de
sous-traitance plus il y a de niveau de
sous-traitance plus les conditions de
travail plus le recours à une main
d'oeuvre non non régulière et et forte
et donc c'est sans doute et on le dit
dans le rapport un point faible qu'il
faut avoir à l'esprit mais
et ce d'autant que la sous-traitance
a pas été limitée dans le nombre de
niveaux et en plus a quand même
relativement peu
bénéficier au TPE PME du du bassin
d'emploi grosso modo 14% de la
sous-traitance à bénéficié à des TPE PME
sur les 14% 9% à des TPE PME
indépendantes et 5% à des TPE PME qui
entre guillemets n'ont que le que le nom
puisque ce sont des filiales de major du
bâtiment
donc il y a c'est un point que nous
mettons en avant le recours à la
sous-traitance aurait pu aurait dû être
limité
tout en respectant le code des marchés
publics
un autre thème qui a été abordé par
Monsieur esquinet Monsieur Le Normand
également sur
la capacité que les que les JO que
l'événement des JO et des JO P vont
pouvoir irriguer ce que d'autres mères
et les territoires ruraux
et notamment si tous les acteurs du
tourisme vont pouvoir avoir des
retombées où ils se trouvent
Stéphane peu l'a dit dans sa
présentation tout à l'heure c'est vrai
que ça c'est un point d'alerte au mois
de février sur le fait que aujourd'hui
tous les acteurs du tourisme se
sentaient un petit peu
un petit peu hors discussion hors
réflexion
et là on a noté quand même que depuis
lors
Olivia Grégoire qui est en charge du
tourisme donc avait réuni les acteurs
les avait associés à
la réflexion et je crois qu'il aura
appartient aujourd'hui effectivement de
profiter de ces touristes internationaux
qui vont venir à Paris en Île-de-France
pour leur donner envie d'aller voir ce
qui se passe sur nos territoires donc là
il y a des formules de séjour qu'il faut
qu'il faut que que les que les
entreprises du tourisme puissent
proposer offrir
à ses nombreux visiteurs parce que par
définition ceux qui vont venir des
quatre coins du monde ils vont venir
pour voir la compétition un jour de jour
mais ils ont quand même vocation à
rester plusieurs jours sur le territoire
national donc qu'il puisse donc
se répandre sur l'ensemble du territoire
national ce serait bien évidemment une
bonne chose j'en profite d'ailleurs pour
dire que beaucoup de nos territoires
sont labellisés terre de jeu le
département des communes
mais c'est pas parce qu'on est labellisé
terre de jeu qu'il va se passer quelque
chose sur nos territoires c'est-à-dire
c'est pas quelque chose de descendant
terre de jeu ça permet d'accéder à un
certain nombre de dispositifs de moyens
qui sont mis à disposition donc des
territoires mais il faut que les
territoires s'approprient le label et à
y voir dans la boîte à outils ce qu'il
aurait permis de faire ou pas faire sur
leur territoire donc ça il faut il faut
vraiment le dire à vos interlocuteurs
aux élus il faut il faut pas il faut pas
attendre que ça descende ça ne descendra
pas il faut vraiment que eux aillent
chercher les dispositifs il y en a je
passe aux Fan Zone qu'on peut mobiliser
au moment des Jeux Olympiques pour pour
animer la place du village où le stade
où le stade de la ville
sur les outre-mer
alors ils sont ils vont être visités par
la flamme donc ça c'est une très bonne
chose il y a une épreuve qui se déroule
donc à l'Outre-mer ce sont les épreuves
de surf en Polynésie
voilà et après donc la mobilisation des
Outre-mer elle se fait comme les
territoires ruraux avec ses labels et
les dispositifs qui peuvent mettre à la
disposition de la population des
associations des élus locaux pour animer
leur territoire
sur le sport scolaire
à chier qui qui m'a interrogé là-dessus
qui nous a interrogé là-dessus
vous l'avez vu dans la présentation il y
a beaucoup de préconisations pour
justement qu'on puisse accompagner le
sport scolaire les chiffres c'est 1,1
millions de licencier UNSS et 700 000
licenciés U7 il faut qu'on puisse aller
beaucoup plus loin et vous avez vu les
préconisations que l'on fait sur lucepp
en termes de moyenne à mettre à la
disposition donc notamment des
professeurs parce qu'aujourd'hui et
c'est ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure ça
repose essentiellement sur le bon
vouloir un peu l'acte militant du
professeur des écoles donc il faut il
faut plus de moyens il faut les
accompagner et il y a vraiment quelque
chose là à aller chercher pour pour
améliorer la pratique sportive de nos
enfants on a préconisé nous
notamment que les licences
UNSS passeport puisse être éligible au
passeport
ce qui serait effectivement une bonne
chose quoi que vous l'aviez
effectivement sollicité dans le cadre de
votre rapport pour avis madame roux donc
on reprend reprend cette proposition ce
que l'on dit aussi c'est pourquoi pas
porter au moins titre expérimental dans
un premier temps l'idée de la double
licence j'ai une licence ens elle me
permet également
d'avoir une activité dans un club de la
ville ou de mon village affilié voilà
donc ça ça pourrait être aussi
intéressant avec le passeport qui
permettrait donc de financer tout ça
derrière donc voilà ça ce sont des
pistes qui permettraient donc à des
enfants par l'école de rentrer dans une
pratique sportive et de la continuer
donc en dehors de l'école et d'avoir
donc cette habitude que nous appelons de
nos vœux
un dernier mot là il y a eu
je suis désolé je me souviens plus qui a
parlé de la question des
de la mixité dans les jeux
excusez-moi mais excusez-moi excusez-moi
pardon mais
bon d'abord Soumia et moi moi-même on a
beaucoup épaulé Marie-Georges Buffet
récemment pour extraire et accueillir
ici ça a été long et difficile l'équipe
féminine l'équipe féminine de handball
de d'Afghanistan
qui sont aujourd'hui en France elles
sont hébergées c'est nous qui nous
beaucoup Marie-Georges Buffet son
association Soumia et moi qui avons
beaucoup aidé à faire qu'ils arrivent en
France après avoir été
retenu
cette réfugié dans un autre pays
elles sont aujourd'hui ici elles
s'entraînent bon nous considérons que
quel que soit la vie du Comité
international olympique
la France doit peser de tout son poids
au sein du comité d'organisation des
Jeux Olympiques et à travers sa
diplomatie pour qu'il ne puisse pas être
admis aux Jeux Olympiques 2024 en France
des équipes qui seraient non mixtes
et que ce soit un principe intangible
bien sûr on nous dit c'est le commita
internal olympique qui a la main sur
l'organisation de la manifestation ces
critères ses règles bon n'empêche que
les jeux ont lieu en France et qu'on a
des choses à dire et qu'il faut le dire
suffisamment tôt et peser suffisamment
fort pour qu'il en soit ainsi ça c'est
la première chose et ensuite je n'ai pas
répondu à une question qui était posée
et qui m'est cher sur la question du
tribunal de Bobigny bien sûr on ne peut
pas avoir une politique zéro délinquance
avec ce que ça veut dire de déferment
devant les tribunaux en plus de la
moyenne sans qu'on donne les moyens au
tribunal de Bobigny parce que c'est le
tribunal le plus concerné et le plus
affaibli du point de vue de ses moyens
des moyens supplémentaires notamment
pour avoir des chambres de comparution
supplémentaires et avoir le nombre de
magistrats supplémentaires aujourd'hui
il y a 57 magistrats au parquet enfin 56
57 postes 56 magistrats et le procureur
de la République estime aujourd'hui à 65
le nombre de magistrats au parquet pour
assumer un standard minimum de justice
dans dans la période et je crois qu'il
faut entendre son message et que le
ministère lui affecte affecte au
tribunal de Bobigny très rapidement même
si c'est de manière exceptionnelle des
moyens supplémentaires
Stéphane me dit c'est une des
résolutions une des propositions la 21
propositions c'est pas les 21 conditions
mais c'est la 21e proposition
merci Monsieur les coraux pour cette
partie de réponse c'est parti de réponse
et nous allons continuer la liste des
questions avec Bertrand sort
merci même la présidente messieurs les
rapporteurs à mon tour je tenais à vous
féliciter à vous remercier pour votre
présentation de qualité j'ai pris
beaucoup de plaisir à lire votre rapport
très complet sur les attentes des
retombées des jobs messieurs vous
soulignez dans votre rapport que le
renforcement des pratiques sportives à
l'école était une ardente obligation et
que l'école reste un lieu privilégié
pour développer le goût et l'envie du
sport à cet effet ministère de
l'Éducation nationale en partenariat
avec le cojob a mis en place 30 minutes
d'activité physique quotidienne les APQ
et deux heures supplémentaires
d'activité physique au collège vous avez
déjà évoqué le sujet vous écrivez
notamment que la PQ doit être vu comme
une activité à part entière et que les
deux heures de sport supplémentaires au
collège doivent être sanctuarisés or
vous relevez également des difficultés
d'application de ces deux dispositifs
aussi pouvez-vous nous faire un premier
bilan de ces dispositifs vous l'avez
bien sûr déjà évoqué et nous faire
savoir comment les établissements
scolaires se sont emparés de ces mesures
selon les territoires je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député Sophie blanc
non mais c'est vrai que
vraiment au moins je vois que vous êtes
extrêmement attentif à tout ça fait
plaisir
merci Madame
monsieur les rapporteurs à l'heure où le
sport s'apprête à être déclaré grande
cause nationale de l'année 2024 la
pratique sportive étudiante bien que
dynamique semble inégal et hétérogène
vous indiquez très précisément aux pages
140 de votre rapport dans deux figures
que depuis le covid 50% des étudiants
ont baissé la durée de leur pratique
sportive un visuel décrit d'ailleurs les
heures de sport abandonnées directement
investis dans l'augmentation du temps
passé devant les écrans alors quel sera
selon vous l'effet jeu sur cet arbitrage
de nos étudiants en faveur des écrans au
détriment du sport et au-delà des
mesures que vous préconisez
n'allons-nous pas assister à un effet
bulle de l'attraction de la pratique
sportive auprès des étudiants je vous
remercie
merci madame la députée car le livre
la présidente messieurs les rapporteurs
sur Stéphane et Stéphane fermeture c'est
le titre du rapport que j'ai remis il y
a un an et demi le sport formidable le
tremplin pour de nombreux enfants de la
République et notamment dans les
quartiers les plus difficiles ils
permettent gommer les différences
sociales et c'est un formidable outil
pour se rencontrer le département des
Yvelines par exemple valorise
l'association La Lucarne ou le sport
est attiré par par des jeunes je les
avais rencontrés à l'époque à Évry
attiré sur un même lieu ces jeunes ces
familles ces entreprises ces acteurs
sociaux il y a Poissy ce simple
événement autour d'une fenêtre doublé
d'un forum pour l'emploi et de
l'insertion avait réuni 1500 personnes
et une vingtaine de recrutements à la
clé prochain édition saison 2 le 13
juillet les Jeux Olympiques
paralympiques se doivent eux aussi
d'être se formidable catalyseur pour
l'emploi d'insertion Stéphane peut comme
Stéphane Mazard leur rappelait tout à
l'heure au delà des bénéfices durables
en matière d'aménagement urbain que vous
avez OK et notamment Seine-Saint-Denis
comment ces jeux permettront à nos
jeunes de s'émanciper par le sport par
le travail comment ces jeux s'inscriront
en termes économiques et d'emploi dans
nos quartiers je vous remercie merci
monsieur le député Rodrigo Arenas
merci Madame présidente merci pour pour
ce rapport qui a le mérite d'éclairer
beaucoup les débats et d'objectiver un
certain nombre de choses contre les
idées reçues mais tout de même je
collègue Jérôme les gars va poser
quelques questions sur le logement qui
méritent peut-être qu'on s'y attarde et
ma vie à modifier mon intervention en
fait je voudrais que vous nous éclairez
si possible sur les pratiques de la
délégation interministériale des Jeux
Olympiques pour faire face à la pénurie
de logements afin d'accueillir les
agents de sécurité les soignants ou
encore tous les volontaires lors de cet
événement international on le sait
aujourd'hui les réseaux sociaux mais
aussi les étudiants qui s'en sont
emparés ont déjà été très agitées
lorsqu'on a parlé des réquisitions de
résidences étudiantes et des internats
lorsqu'il a été question de demander
après de 3000 étudiants de quitter leur
logement en préalable pour le temps des
jeux donc je vous dépose donc clairement
la question cette façon là si vous avez
évidemment les éléments pour répondre
les locataires des logements sociaux
seront-ils invités à céder leur logement
comme salaire d'être le cas le temps des
JO et les BA sociaux ont-ils reçu pour
consigne de réserver des logements pour
les Jeux Olympiques et de les laisser
ainsi en attente d'attribution ce qui
vous en conviendrait aurait de fait un
impact direct à la fois sur l'économie
des quartiers concernés sur le court
terme mais aussi sur le long terme en
sachant que la ville de Saint-Denis et
je finis là-dessus madame la Présidente
a bien montré que la théorie du
ruissellement est assez limitée quand on
s'occupe des logements sans changer la
vie des gens on n'a pas l'effet escompté
sur le long terme merci de votre
tolérance madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le député Emmanuel Antoine
la
Président Monsieur les rapporteurs je je
souhaiterais revenir sur les retombées
économiques des jeux dans les
territoires vous avez évoqué le fait que
sur les 663 millions d'euros de marchés
attribués à des pmet TPE 103 millions
d'euros ont été attribués à des TPE et
PME implantés en Seine-Saint-Denis soit
15,5 % des marchés actuels octroyés à
des pmetpe et si l'on prend en compte
l'ensemble des pmet TPE installés en
Île-de-France le pourcentage atteint
65%. ces chiffres démontrent des
retombées économiques locales
importantes mais elle bénéficie avant
tout à l'Île-de-France région déjà la
plus dynamique économiquement de notre
pays ces Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques seront toutefois une
réussite pour le pays s'ils irriguent
l'ensemble de notre territoire national
et serait dommage qu'il bénéficie avant
tout à l'économie francilienne à
croissant encore les déséquilibres entre
les territoires alors aussi quel
retombées économique peut-on envisager
pour les autres régions françaises et en
particulier nos territoires ruraux
merci madame la députée Lisette Paulette
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues tout
d'abord un grand merci pour votre
rapport d'information qui permet d'avoir
un aperçu clair des retombées des jobs
ou soulevez deux problématiques
importantes le transport et la sécurité
je me pencherai sur ce deuxième enjeu
des forces de sécurité intérieure vont
devoir relever un défi un défi
capacitaire vous estimez en effet
qu'entre 20000 et 30 000 agences seront
nécessaires chaque jour pour assurer la
sécurité des sites un volume d'effectif
qui ne sera vraisemblablement vrai
semblablement pas atteint aujourd'hui ce
secteur souffre d'une impopularité
croissante et des difficultés de
recrutement sont à prévoir et pourtant
un équilibre doit être assuré entre les
missions de sécurité liées aux Jeux
olympiques et le maintien de la sécurité
sur l'ensemble du territoire un plan B
est-il prévu pour relever le ce défi si
le recrutement ne se fait pas attendre
je vous remercie
merci madame la députée Paul Vanier
merci madame la Présidente merci
messieurs les rapporteurs votre rapport
rappellent la volonté et affiché
d'organiser les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques dans des conditions
sociales je cite exemplaires leur
préparation conduit pourtant déjà à
fragiliser les populations les plus
vulnérables d'Île-de-France en mars
dernier le ministre de la Ville et du
logement vous l'avez évoqué demander au
préfet de région de créer des SAS
d'accueil temporaires régionaux pour y
déplacer et accueillir les personnes
sans abri de la région depuis des
centaines de sans-abris sont chaque mois
évacués d'hôtels sociaux cette politique
s'apparente à une stratégie d'éviction
des personnes sans domicile destinées à
les faire disparaître des rues de Paris
à l'approche des Jeux Olympiques elle
encourage certaines municipalités à
fermer des structures d'accueil dans ma
circonscription le maire d'Argenteuil a
ainsi brutalement annoncé la fermeture
du centre d'hébergement d'urgence de la
ville cet été avec toutes les
conséquences dramatiques pour la santé
de personnes accueillies en termes
d'accès et de maintien dans l'emploi ou
d'état sanitaire messieurs les
rapporteurs comment évaluez vous les
conséquences des Jeux Olympiques pour
les personnes sans abri d'Île-de-France
accourent et à moyen terme c'est à dire
au-delà de des épreuves sportives
organisées l'année prochaine dans notre
pays
merci monsieur le député
Francis Dubois
merci madame la Présidente
messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues vous mentionnez dans votre
rapport un manque flagrant
d'installation sportive de proximité
pourtant un engagement sans faille des
collectivités territoriales permet de
faire bénéficier aux élèves
d'installation sportive de qualité 70%
de ses installations appartiennent au
bloc communal le contribution est
estimée à 12,5 milliards sur le double
du budget de l'État consacré au sport en
milieu rural notamment Corrèze nous
constatons un manque flagrant
d'installation sportive de proximité se
fait limite voire empêche l'enseignement
et la pratique de certaines disciplines
sportives l'enveloppe budgétaire de
l'État du plan de 5000 équipement
sportifs de proximité s'élève à 109
millions d'euros pour 2023 alors que les
239 dossiers déposés par les
collectivités territoriales représentent
398 millions
d'euros le plan s'avère très sous
dimensionné proposez-vous de
dimensionner ce plan des équipements
sportifs pour qu'ils puissent bénéficier
davantage aux communes rurales une
augmentation des DETR une augmentation
des dotations de soutien aux
investissements locaux une augmentation
des fonds verts pour la rénovation dans
le cas de transition énergétique il est
primordial que les communes rurales sous
dotées en équipement sportifs puissent
bénéficier de ce plan merci merci
monsieur le député
Bénédicte ozano
merci Madame ma présidente messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues ma question
porte sur vos recommandations de la
rubrique tourisme et en particulier sur
les locations meublées de tourisme vous
mettez en exergue dans votre rapport le
manque d'hébergement touristique
notamment en Île-de-France ce qui ne
surprend personne au détour de ce
constat vous faites des recommandations
qui sont j'en suis sûr destinée à
augmenter les places d'hébergement
rendre obligatoire l'enregistrement de
tous les meublés de tourisme abaisser le
nombre de jours de location autorisés et
les assujettir à la TVA comme vous
l'avez souligné en introduction monsieur
le rapporteur peu si je traduis ce sera
en réalité restriction du droit de
disposer de son bien contraintes
supplémentaire alors que les Français
crèvent des règlementsations
pléthoriques augmentation de l'impôt
alors que nous sommes déjà les plus
imposés de l'OCDE par quel miracle
pensez-vous à les créer de l'hébergement
touristique supplémentaire en
restreignant la liberté des
propriétaires Aires et en augmentant
leurs impôts je vous remercie
merci madame la députée Léo Walter
merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues rapporteur dans l'évaluation
des retombées économiques et sociales
des jeux pour la France ce sur quoi je
souhaite à nouveau vous interroger peut
sembler une goutte d'eau mais pour les
territoires comme le mien qui
n'accueille aucune épreuve olympique ce
sera le seul impact concret et direct
des Jeux olympiques et paralympiques le
15 février dernier lors de votre point
d'étape je vous avais en effet alerté
sur le coût du relais de la flamme
olympique pour rappel il s'élève pour
les départements qu'il accueillent à
180.000 euros la journée sans compter
les dépenses engagées par les villes
étapes sans compter non plus comme le
noter la Cour des comptes le coût de la
sécurité dont la répartition du
financement entre les pouvoirs publics
et l'organisateur n'est pas clair sauf
erreur de ma part votre rapport ne
mentionne le relais de la flamme qu'une
fois à la page 80 et c'est justement
pour s'inquiéter de la sécurisation de
son parcours
mes questions sont donc les suivantes le
coût réel pour les deniers publics et la
répartition des dépenses de sécurité
avec l'opérateur privé sont-ils
aujourd'hui établis et encore une fois
qu'elle retombée économique quel
héritage matériel et immatériel du
relais de la flamme je vous remercie
merci Monsieur député monsieur les corps
rapporteurs
oui
mais vous étiez pas très cher collègue
mais je vais vous donner la parole bien
volontiers donc Estelle Forest et
ensuite
Emmanuel Pellerin
oui moi c'est une question très rapide
en effet qui recoupe celle que vient de
poser notre collègue Léo Walter sur le
passage de la flamme puisqu'on vient
d'avoir le tracé un peu officiel mon
département est dans le même cas que le
sien c'est-à-dire que il aura
effectivement le passage de flammes sans
accueillir des preuves même si on a des
entraînements également chez nous je me
demandais pour essayer d'être
constructive si vous avez dans lors de
vos auditions entendu des bonnes
pratiques qui permettrait de valoriser
justement ce passage de flammes et toi
entendu que moi aussi je trouve que
c'est quand même une dépense conséquente
avec des enjeux de sécurité que je ne
néglige pas et que donc j'aimerais que
le territoire puisse en bénéficier voilà
sont juste au niveau je vous remercie
merci madame la députée Emmanuel
Pellerin merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur les rapporteurs je salue
vivement la qualité de votre travaux qui
nous donne une idée précise des
retombées des Jeux Olympiques et par le
pic 2024 sur le tissu économique et
associatif local
comme vous l'avez souligné dans votre
rapport l'effort financier consenti par
l'État 11 millions d'euros et les
collectivités territoriales pour offrir
un million de billets à des Français de
conditions modestes étaient
indispensable
alors que près de 10 millions de billets
sont en vente les prix affichés restent
cependant très élevés 80% des billets
sont à plus de 24 euros à titre
d'illustration selon le site officiel
des Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
Paris 2024 une place de finale
d'athlétisme coûte entre 125 et 980
euros dans ces conditions il est
difficile d'expliquer de faire accepter
de tel prix aux Français ma question la
suivante comment le comité
d'organisation compte-t-il promouvoir la
vente de billets auprès des populations
défavorisées et des associations à but
non lucratif merci infiniment merci
monsieur le député monsieur le
co-président du groupe de travail vous
perdra merci madame la Présidente non
j'ai juste une question puisque le
groupe de travail effectue de nombreux
déplacements et lors d'un de nos
déplacements au village olympique nous
avions constaté qu'un établissement
scolaire
un collège notamment
se trouve dans l'enclave du village
olympique ce qui entraînera bien
évidemment la fermeture avant l'arrivée
des Jeux Olympiques et de la préparation
en tout cas des Jeux Olympiques et ne
ré-ouvrira qu'après la fin des Jeux
paralympiques alors est-ce que vous avez
pu étudier ce sujet pouvez-vous nous en
dire plus si ce sujet a été anticipé
afin que les élèves puissent avoir un
établissement scolaire pour la fin
d'année pour le brevet et bien
évidemment pour la rentrée scolaire
2024-2025 merci beaucoup merci monsieur
le député monsieur les corps rapporteur
c'est à vous pour la réponse pour les
réponses
bon je démarre
en vrac on se répartit
nos réponses sont en vrac
je commence par la dernière question
normalement c'est un sujet bien sûr
normalement
la rentrée scolaire dans ce collège
devrait pouvoir
être un peu décalé et cohabiter il
n'aura pas l'avoir de conséquences enfin
en tout cas la piste recherchée c'est de
pouvoir
faire cohabiter une rentrée scolaire peu
décalée avec avec la tenue des Jeux
paralympiques puisque bon
la ville le département
le rectorat il travaille peut-être que
au final ce sera une autre solution mais
pour l'instant la
voilà la solution privilégiée et
celle-là moi je voudrais revenir en deux
mots sur la question du logement
étudiant qui a été posé
à plusieurs reprises pour l'instant on a
eu des auditions sur le sujet bon
effectivement il y a une recherche
auprès du CROUS de 3000 3000 chambres
pour pouvoir héberger des salariés ou
des des bénévoles pendant les Jeux bon
après conisation qu'on a faite et des
garanties qu'on nous a donné j'ai été
vérifié moi à Saint-Denis parce que on
était directement concernés c'est quand
même de le faire avec des mises à
disposition qui ont déjà existé dans
dans le passé c'est-à-dire que souvent
quand même la plupart des résidences
étudiantes puisque ce ne sont pas des
beaux à duré indéterminée c'est c'est ce
qu'on appelle des
ce n'est pas un bail c'est un contrat de
location donc souvent il y a quand même
des beaucoup de résidences qui sont
vides ou quasiment vides pendant l'été
et donc là il s'agit de les mobiliser
pendant une période où il y a pas
d'activité universitaires mais sans
obliger
des étudiants qui resteraient dans leur
résidence l'été à déménagé ou alors en
leur proposant dans à proximité des
hébergements
équivalents du point de vue du prix et
du point de vue de la de la localisation
enfin en tout cas il y a cette recherche
de mobiliser 3000 chambres étudiantes
pour loger des des personnels liés au
jeu sans être
que sans que ce soit
sans que c'est de conséquences sur les
étudiants après sur les hébergements
d'urgence là qu'ils sont posés entre
autres beaucoup d'entre vous et Paul
vaniers en particulier il y a deux
sujets
moi enfin
il y a une une loi qui est passée et une
volonté du gouvernement que tout ce qui
est hébergement de demandeurs d'asile
dans dans la région parisienne puisse
être parti sur le territoire national et
ça c'est indépendant des Jeux Olympiques
c'est la résidence à Saint-Brévin pour
prendre et d'autres en France
bon ça j'ai envie de dire Jeux
olympiques ou pas Jeux Olympiques c'est
une décision que je crois enfin pour ma
part je salue plutôt que d'essayer de de
de répartir sur le territoire national
et puis d'avoir des conditions
d'hébergement qui soit plus dignes que
ce que la seule région Île-de-France est
en capacité d'accueillir après j'ai été
mon attention a été attirée par un
certain nombre de préfets à l'égalité
des chances par des associations qui
s'occupent de l'hébergement d'urgence
sur des fermetures d'hébergement
d'urgence mais qui sont sans lien avec
les Jeux Olympiques c'est-à-dire que là
il y a une réduction de l'offre
simplement d'urgence non pas pour situer
des hébergements d'urgence à l'accueil
pendant les Jeux olympiques mais qui
sont des restrictions budgétaires sur le
financement de l'hébergement d'urgence
donc ça c'est un point d'inquiétude moi
je tiens à votre disposition une
question écrite que j'ai réalisé il y a
très peu de temps au ministre du
Logement sur le sujet inspiré par ce que
mon rapportait un certain nombre
d'associations mais aussi de d'agent de
l'État
[Musique]
bon donc là il y a une inquiétude mais
qui est plus une inquiétude de mon point
de vue budgétaire qu'une inquiétude liée
aux Jeux olympiques et après on a
troisième volet où là on a on attire
l'attention dans notre rapport c'est que
vous avez toute une série d'hôteliers
qui pour des raisons X ou Y que je vais
pas commenter ici ont signé plutôt que
d'avoir une activité hôtelière classique
ont signé des contrats par exemple avec
le Samu social qui réservait à l'année
leur hôtel
et donc il y avait plus d'activités
hôtelières puisque c'est le Samu social
qui faisait en gros un chèque de
location de l'ensemble des chambres pour
toute l'année et tous les jours de
l'année qui aujourd'hui veulent
reprendre la main sur leur hôtel casser
les beaux les contrats c'est pas des
beaux casser les contrats avec par
exemple Samu social ou d'autres
associations pour pouvoir retrouver une
activité autonière classique pendant les
Jeux Olympiques et là ça pose un
problème parce que ça fait baisser et en
lien direct avec les Jeux Olympiques ça
fait baisser considérablement le nombre
d'hébergements d'urgence donc là il faut
là aussi avoir la mesure et ne pas
forcément accepter
tous ces va-et-vient entre les
différents statues de l'hôtellerie on
peut pas bénéficier du Samu Social
pendant des années et puis au moment des
jeux se retirer du contrat avec les
samues sociales pour ensuite y revenir
les jeux passés il y a quand même un peu
de moralité à mettre dans dans cette
affaire ensuite
sur ce que disait rodrigoa Arenas il y a
pas de risque sur les logements sociaux
les logements sociaux c'est des beaux
qui ne sont pas du tout rétractables
par le bailleur c'est même par rapport
au beau du privé c'est des beaux a duré
indéterminée donc il y a pas de de
possibilités juridique pour un bailleur
social de mettre un terme au bail qui le
lit avec tel ou tel locataire pour
mettre le logement à d'autres à d'autres
fins
sur ce plan il y a pas il y a pas de il
y a pas de risque
on est on est protégé après sur la
question de la place du sport
alors sur la question de Carl olive bon
moi je pense quand même
Stéphane Mazar le disait tout à l'heure
on considère que l'engouement populaire
pour les jeunes n'est pas encore
au top enfin voilà c'est pas encore au
rendez-vous on peut il y a aussi un lien
on va pas se mentir ici il y a aussi un
lien dans entre le climat le climat du
pays le climat social dans le pays
indépendamment de ce qu'on pensait les
uns les autres et puis les jeux le fait
que par exemple les sondages sur
l'acceptabilité des jeux et
l'enthousiasme pour les jeux d'il y a un
an était
plus important il y a un an qu'ils le
sont aujourd'hui sont plutôt une
source quand même d'inquiétude sur
laquelle il faut il faut qu'on fasse
attention c'est la raison pour laquelle
tout le plan des bénévoles tout le plan
de formation sur la sécurité privée avec
en trois semaines tout
les offres que vont pouvoir
faire les Jeux Olympiques en matière
d'emploi tout ça doit nous permettre
aussi dans d'embarquer davantage la
population on attire l'attention dans la
pension deux choses qui nous semblent
faibles nous on considère que
l'éducation nationale c'est pas vrai
partout bien sûr on a toujours des
contre-exemples mais globalement
l'éducation nationale n'a pas fait des
Jeux Olympiques avec un vecteur
pédagogique qui permettent de faire à
travers les jeux moi je l'avais vécu
pendant la coupe du monde de foot où il
y avait eu des des kits pédagogiques
pour faire aller de la géographie et de
l'histoire et enfin bref de toute une
série de matières à travers un événement
comme ça qui était palpable là pour le
coup c'est pas tout à fait le cas sur
les Jeux Olympiques j'espère que ça le
sera à la rentrée parce que on sait que
quand un pays on l'embarque aussi à
travers la façon dont les enfants et les
jeunes s'emparent du sujet mobilisent
aussi leurs parents donc il y a un
retard du côté de l'éducation nationale
pour que dans les les enseignements de
l'année 2023 2024 il y est à travers les
jeux toute série de d'axes pour
pédagogique qui permettent d'embarquer
les les jeunes après le sport et je
finis juste par là bon là c'est plus
peut-être une note personnelle encore
que on a eu deux lois olympiques on en a
une une en 2018 et puis une là il y a
quelques mois c'est deux lois Olympiques
qui nous permettaient de nous mettre en
règle entre guillemets pour bien
organiser les Jeux la première c'était
beaucoup sur les questions d'urbanisme
la deuxième sur les questions de
sécurité
dès 2018 on avait posé la question oui
mais il faut quand même une grande loi
d'orientation sur le sport
au moment où la France va accueillir les
Jeux olympiques à le moment où l'année
2024 va être l'année du sport
ou le sport grande cause nationale bon
aujourd'hui notre pays n'a pas sa grande
loi d'orientation sur le sport elle a eu
deux lois olympique mais de loi
olympique qui parlaient peu de sport il
y a la loi démocratisée d'espoir mais il
y a pas de loi on voit bien à travers
le gouvernement a dit qu'il allait le
faire parce que 2018 il a été répondu
qu'il y aura une grande loi
d'orientation sur le sport pour
l'instant c'est ce qui a été dit en 2018
néo pour l'instant pas aujourd'hui
effectivement donc la ministre qui a été
interrogée nous a dit qu'il y en aurait
une bon ça peut intervenir après des
jeux c'est pas mais il faut que dans
notre pays il y a une grande loi
d'orientation sur les sports qui donnent
à la fois au club au sport scolaire
enfin aux soupe à l'accès aux paraport
enfin bref qui qui nous fasse monter
d'un cran dans la pratique du sport dans
notre pays
bien
sur la flamme pour répondre à
monsieur Walter et Madame pollest sur le
alors
180000 effectivement c'était le ticket
d'entrée pour le département pour
accueillir donc le parcours de la flamme
il appartient à chaque département de
faire vivre l'événement sur lequel
d'ailleurs les départements j'espère
compte aussi pour mettre en avant leur
territoire et créer des retombées
économiques aussi pour pour l'ensemble
de leur population on peut penser quand
même que le parcours de la flamme va
donner à voir ce qui est le plus beau
dans les départements pour les
départements c'est sûrement l'occasion
aussi de mettre en valeur des
personnalités du territoire des
associations
voilà de faire passer des messages en
termes de citoyenneté de lutte contre
les discriminations etc en fait je pense
que c'est un outil à partir duquel on
peut
mener beaucoup d'actions et faire passer
beaucoup de messages et donner à voir ce
qu'il y a de mieux dans chaque
territoire voilà et si et s'il y a une
couverture médiatique
qu'on peut espérer quand même parce que
le parcours de la flamme il va être
quand même suivi il peut y avoir quand
même des retombées assez importantes
pour les territoires je comprends un peu
avec quand une ville accueille autour de
France ce soit l'arrivée le départ ou
qu'on soit ville étape il y a un ticket
d'entrée d'ailleurs qui peut prouver au
centre un petit peu à celui-ci et qui
interne de retombées économique sur les
années qui suivent en termes de de
l'activité touristique notamment permet
d'avoir un retour sur investissement
assez assez important sur la
sécurisation qui est un vrai sujet c'est
à la charge bien évidemment des
collectivités qui accueillent le
parcours de la flamme il y a le contrat
qui est signé une contractualisation qui
est qui est effective entre le
département et les organisateurs
voilà ce qui est un comble aujourd'hui à
au Koso je crois que c'est juste
d'organiser un petit peu la
parade quoi la parade de la flamme
c'est-à-dire le lien entre entre les
différents les différents territoires
moi je crois que ça peut être
encore une fois vous l'avez dit
peut-être à votre département c'est le
seul moment où de manière tangible on va
on va voir les yeux qui brillent sur le
terrain
et qu'il pourrait y avoir une espèce de
communion même si encore une fois comme
je disais tout à l'heure il faut
s'approprier les dispositifs terre de
jeu qui permet de mobiliser les
populations et de créer du lien mais je
crois que c'est ça peut marquer une
génération on peut imaginer quand même
que les enfants qui vont se retrouver
sur le bord de la route qui vont voir
passer la flamme avec j'imagine un
travail qui va être fait en amont par
les enseignants par les clubs de sport
et puis le débrief à naval ça peut faire
quand même briller les yeux des enfants
et marquer une génération parce que
c'est tous les 100 ans
[Musique]
monsieur sort et d'autres vous m'avez
vous nous avez interrogé sur
enfin vous vous avez interpellé sur le
fait que avait été mis en place donc les
30 minutes de la PQ au quotidien dans
les écoles primaires
l'expérimentation des heures
supplémentaires de PS dans dans les
collèges
il est difficile aujourd'hui d'évaluer
ces dispositifs c'est trop tôt on peut
pas savoir si effectivement c'est
mais quand même ce qu'on a noté nous si
on prend rien que l'exemple de 30
minutes d'API
c'est que ça va dépendre l'établissement
à l'autre ça va dépendre beaucoup
de la pétance des compétences de la
professeure des écoles ou du professeur
des écoles il y a des écoles qui ont
reçu des kits il y a des écoles qui
n'ont pas reçu les kits même si il est
mis à la disposition du Coran seniant
notamment par par le cozoop ou du
ministère des des fiches pédagogiques
qui sont très bien faites enfin voilà on
sent que il y a pas il y a pas
d'uniformité dans le déploiement de ces
dispositifs c'est très bien on le salue
et je trouve que profiter des jeux
olympiques pour mettre en place des
mesures aussi fortes de place de
l'activité physique c'est important il
fallait le faire mais il faudra pas
s'arrêter là et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous on souhaite aller plus
loin mais avec une substitution de la PQ
par un véritable cours de PS parce que
c'est un enseignement qui dépasse
largement le fait de se bouger
et qui véhicule plein d'autres choses
donc voilà ce sont les annonces les
réseaux
les préconisations fortes que nous
formulons dans
notre dans notre rapport sur les
territoires ruraux
vous êtes plusieurs là aussi à m'avoir à
nous avoir interrogé
et notamment le dispositif 5000 terrain
de jeu c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui entre
le nombre de dossiers déposés et les
budgets
alloués au dispositif il y a un gap trop
important nous ce qu'on préconise de le
pérenniser dans le temps ça ne s'arrête
pas là au moment des jeux il va falloir
continuer donc à équiper nos territoires
de ces petits infrastructures qui sont
très utiles très riches
et en préconise d'augmenter bien sûr le
budget dédié
ça me permet de rebondir sur
l'enseignement supérieur nous on dit que
les universités devraient être éligibles
au dispositif sanitaire de jeu on voit
que la pratique des étudiants
qui est faible parce que l'habitude
c'est encore une fois n'a pas été
travaillé à l'école au collège au lycée
il y a une déperditions très importantes
entre le collège et le lycée puis alors
ensuite avec les études supérieures
c'est encore plus important le
décrochage mais on voit qu'aujourd'hui
les pratiques des étudiants elle est
très informelle et justement le type
d'équipement qui permet d'être financé
par le programme sanitaire de jeu je
crois correspond pas mal à ce que
peuvent attendre des étudiants ça peut
être le terrain de basket 3/3 voilà ce
type d'infrastructure très facile à
mobiliser et à mettre en œuvre sur un
campus universitaire même s'il est pas
très important sur le plan de la
superficie ou de l'espace disponible et
ça permettrait d'avoir ces pratiques
informelles qui correspond encore une
fois à la pétanque des des étudiants
je crois qu'on a à peu près fait le tour
peut-être
pour répondre à Carl olive on invite à
faire venir la lucarne à l'Assemblée
nationale pour se mesurer
à cette épreuve qui crée du lien au-delà
de mettre un ballon dans une lucarne et
ça permet de dire oui que son rapport
c'était
faire nation par le sport
et nous on a l'ambition effectivement
qu'avec les jeux et ce phénomène
d'accélération que peut avoir les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques dans notre
pays on est cette nation plus sportive
dans la pratique dans l'appétence pour
le sport dans la façon dont le sport
peut créer des liens et des altérités
donc voilà c'est tout l'objet de de ce
rapport et comme on le disait tout à
l'heure on a devant nous donc un
événement important majeur et il fera se
retrouver après en terme d'héritage en
tout cas on pense qu'il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de choses qui ont été des
politiques publiques qui ont été initiés
mises en oeuvre qu'elle mérite d'être
confortée avec une volonté politique
très forte de faire du sport un levier
essentiel pour notre pour notre pays
merci
merci beaucoup messieurs les deux corps
rapporteurs pour la qualité du travail
de l'engagement et des réponses que vous
avez pu fournir ce matin moi je donc on
a plusieurs choses à faire encore avant
à la fin des travaux mais notamment donc
autoriser la publication du rapport
puisque il appartient à la Commission
d'autoriser la publication du rapport de
la mission d'information en application
du septième alinéa de l'article 145 du
Règlement de l'Assemblée nationale qui
est pour
qui est contre à l'unanimité la
publication est autorisée bravo à vous
deux